as we sit here and talk to these small
business owners they have got to be
worried about the US economy you're
looking at them from CEO from chairman
seats but what do you really think the
US economy looks like right now makeover
you know it is clearly a lot of job
creation there's clearly a lot of angst
among people that we're not addressing
the big issues like immigration and tax
policy and guns and the streets there's
worrisome things happening all around
the world but the average person is not
doing all that badly in all fairness to
Obama during his administration in the
last few years jobs have been created in
the jobless rate is way down still
plenty of people that don't have the
kind of jobs they want don't have
full-time jobs and that sort of thing
there's always going to be problems so
it's it's not perfect and I certainly am
very worried about the future Iran and
all of these different things but the
average small businessman seems to be a
business person seems to be coming back
starting another business and being able
to create jobs I agree i think the
sentiment is very negative you know
we're in the middle of an election cycle
and there's a lot of things that are
wrong with the economy and a lot of
things that could go wrong and my core
job requires me to worry and to think
about and deal with all the things that
could go wrong but I think if you just
kept it simple you'd say that the United
States is growing almost extra I'm kind
of a trend growth you know whether it's
two and a half or just under three
percent growth or maybe even a little
above it well no but a round trend
growth with interest rate policy and for
very good reason at levels as if we were
in a recession so financial conditions
are very easy the energy situation most
of the economies of Europe have broken
to the high side and I'd say if you just
looked at it very simply things were
going to go you know very well and then
with a number of things to worry about
but that's an added complexity that
people are putting in I would say keep
it simple and things are moving forward